I want to know is there a quick way
rather than me drawing every single
right is there a faster way to work out
this relationship what's going on okay
and that's what we're going to show you
I'll show you that so in your square
here's the construction I'd like you to
put in a few lines with your rulers okay
what we're gonna do is up in the top
right hand left hand corner we're going
to if you off one of these right because
it's a square you can take on lining or
so no need to rub Italian - yeah I
missed one dimension shares this corner
with your writing okay so draw it
roughly I'll give you a dislike this
tight I said three centimeters - no okay
so this time to measure that up I hope
yours is big enough to do that if you
measure that three centimeters and put
in a little mark there okay I want you
to also measure out that same distance
three centimeters from this opposite
corner and I'm gonna go this way
something like that
sorry I missed the step okay I've got
another point there okay that's the line
I want you to join up that's gonna form
all right angles right sorry about that
better than catch it okay so you've
drawn that in you've got that that
distance there is the same as that
distance they're not exactly the same
way I want you to take that same
distance and measure it from this corner
over here
so I've got three centimeters happening
there and then they'll be a little much
okay and then I want you to join up this
here like so okay so what you should
find now is I've got two triangles they
kind of look the same but they've been
rotated around think back to last year
when you were looking at symmetry okay
what my creating here is a shape with
rotational symmetry or point symmetry
rows there you measure three centimeters
here we're going to do one more
measurement three centimeters this time
left-hand corner three centimeters okay
you're gonna put in a little mark there
and now I'm going to join up the last
two lines okay so I'm going to join up
this triangle which you can see is
opposite my very first triangle its
opposite directly facing that side and
my last triangle okay yes give you a
second so now that we put this in this
part is going to be tricky so hold on to
your hats okay
don't worry though I wouldn't pressure
too much you know writing everything
down because everything I'm bout to
write down I will keep on the board so
it might be wise of you actually just
put your pen down for a minute
just watch when I'm finished writing
everything who spammed the board and you
can copy it down but for now it'll be
more important just to forward what's
actually happening okay so look at the
very first triangle we drew up in the
top left hand corner
okay effect I'm gonna get it very first
triangle okay so here we go I'm gonna
triangle up here and I'm trying to work
out what's the relationship between all
of these sides so don't work out how
they relate I kind of need to label them
so I can say this one's this
this one's that rather than talk about
you know that side and then the other
side and then the one which is it the
two sides have just talked about labels
are much more helpful it's gonna call
that a B and C so just what should just
mentally kind of block out the rest of
the diagram for a second so you can see
you've got a B and C and that's what I'm
trying to work out a relationship right
so you see that triangle now think
remember how we constructed this that
triangle over there is exactly the same
as these three other triangles they've
just been sort of moved around like a
okay so therefore where else can I put a
yeah look carefully on my diagram right
we'll enjoy making suggestion very good
that's how we mentioned out like the
three centimeters right on your diagram
so got a up here got a down here and
I've got a over here as well I'll give
you a second why don't you label your
diagram just like mine before it gets a
little more busy okay okay what else do
we have here I got this side see I'm
gonna leave off B for a second okay cuz
I think I've got enough B's on there
where else can you see the letter C yeah
fantastic so there's my big square in
blue and all of these ones on the inside
they're all C as well because all of
these triangles are the same okay all
those triangles are the same now I can
go through and I can prove it properly
for you but just for the sake of time
I'm just gonna state it and you can have
it think about it later this shape in
the mill here it can be one of two kinds
of shapes it's got two choices right
before we say which one it is what are
the two possibilities for this process
Rachel okay it could be square or it
could be a diamond and the other name
for that is I start with our rhombus
very good same same thing different name
rhombuses are more descriptive names I
prefer them so this thing could be a
rhombus or a square now just as it
happens it is actually a square if you'd
like me to show you the full proof for
that I will stop don't pay that long but
for now it's not that important so now
what am I trying to do try to get some
relationships between all of these
different shapes together okay so for
instance have a look at the big square
big blue square that we started with
okay it's a square
how long are each of the sides
everyone's got a different number but
according to how I've labeled them every
side
is a plus B can you see that yeah a plus
B every sign is the same so for what I
know the area of this whole square how
do you find the area of a square if you
know it's assignment you just it's a
square
so you squared by 8 plus B times a plus
B so I'm just gonna write sweat you
happy with that
okay now that's one way of looking at it
in maths one of the most useful things
to do is look at a problem and look at
it from two different angles right and
you always discover something new so I
looked at it as one big square but it's
not just a big square we cut it up into
a whole bunch of slices right have a
look at the little different chunks what
we got it yet okay so for starters I've
got this square in the middle and you
all told me that the side length is C so
it's seeds but I also have these
triangles that I drew right how many
triangles my god oh I've got four of
them four times now think back hmm this
has been a little while now what's the
area of a triangle very good let me say
that again in the kitchen catch it
length times prep and then you divide by
two take half okay now the length and
breadth of all my triangles is the same
two length is a and the breadth is B so
it's four times length breadth / - okay
I'm gonna pause for a second why don't
you jump that down and that's an
important idea before we carry on any
further so the idea is a plus B all
squared even label it the way I have
it's the big square right what's C
squared that's the smaller square on the
inside small square
okay and then what's this thing trailing
off on the end it's four triangles right
four triangles okay you'll find me doing
this a lot by the way and I highly
encourage you to do it whenever you
write an equation it's a final that you
know what the equation means it's not
just random letters flying around okay
they actually stand for different things
fantastic habit to get into particularly
when you write an equation for the first
time you say you know where did that
come from
what's it actually represent okay now
this is what we're gonna work on a here
it does look a little bit complicated
but we can work with it all right
we'll start with the right-hand side
first it's actually a bit easier I've
got a C squared now have a look at this
we can simplify this
can't we think back to your fractions
right that four is really on the
numerator right so I've got four over -
how should I write that instead four
over two so that's four / - isn't it
and four divided by two is just - it's
just - okay so key see what I've done
here I've cancelled here the equivalent
fraction up here four over two is equal
to two over one but we don't really need
to write over one do it okay so a to a B
now let's have a look at the left-hand
side this is tricky a plus B and when
you stick a square on them right that's
shorthand it's shorthand for this okay
now everyone go to different points
whatever that there were moments ago and
it's all your algebra lossy so what can
assume you know what this is right away
we're just gonna work on it together
okay think about the distributive law I
wonder if you remember this from last
year when you expanding brackets okay so
for example give you a numerical example
don't write this one just follow it oops
if I gave you this
20 okay so this is a fairly big number
that we're gonna have some multiply how
can I unpack this I've got a couple of
choices I can add these two gives me
four good add these two excuse me 30 and
then I multiply through that's fine okay
but there's another way I can do it
right one plus three times that means I
should have one of them and I should
have three of them just look at that for
a second
see if that sort of seems familiar to
you right multiplying this across here
means I want one of them and then I want
three of them so I've written them now
out separately okay
now then I can go ahead and I can expand
I'll get the same answer at the end okay
I'm gonna do exactly the same thing hue
watch really carefully a plus B times
all of that right will be a times that
plus can anyone still leave me what's
gonna be on the NTA cool I'm not gonna
get all hung up on it because actually
they're not even cool brackets they call
parentheses but no one calls and written
season why everything is fine for now
okay so there you go I've expanded this
out okay I'm just gonna write the left
the right hand side again I haven't done
anything to that okay
now this we can have a look at expanding
brackets is something we've seen before
okay but we haven't had that much
practice on it so let's keep the cigar a
times a we have a shorthand for that
it's a square a times B we just have a
shorthand for that which is a B we've
seen that haven't we a B a times B okay
I've done the first lot that's turned
into that what's gonna happen here I'm
gonna try and do it in order as best I
can
that made that way I won't forget turns
my axis so do these two first B and a
when I multiply them together you can
multiply numbers in whatever what do you
like right 3 times 5 5 times 3 same
thing so I'm gonna write it in this
order okay
baa B same thing and then the B Strep
that you mentioned before are we okay so
far yep following okay I'm just gonna
write the right-hand side another time I
haven't done anything to it okay now on
the left-hand side
there's my second last line so if you
followed this far well done see these
two guys we have a special name for
these right they look the same so we
call them like terms do you remember
this from washi yeah we can collect like
terms I've got one here and I've got one
here so how many do I have in total -
I've got a squared two of them like you
just told me and B squared so far so
good here comes the last line this is an
equation right I always love to pick up
with equations what you're saying is
you've got two things I've got two
things and they're exactly equal to each
other you might be looking at them in
slightly different ways but they're the
same right so anything you do to one
side you can do to the other
well have a look I've got a - a B over
here and it's soo a B over here they're
the same right so I can get rid of them
from both sides it's like having a set
of scales and you take the same thing
away from both sides it's still equal
right so I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
remove it from one side and remove it
from the elbow you see that and he's my
final line what's left on the left-hand
side
a squared
and be square what's left on the
right-hand side see that there that that
in big bold letters put a box around it
that is Pythagoras's theorem
he said if you know what the two shorter
sides are you square them and now give
you the longest side the hypotenuse
squared
that's Pythagoras theorem you might
notice by the way it's got an apostrophe
on the end because it's not Pythagoras
theorem
it's the theorem that belongs to
Pythagoras so it's an apostrophe